sow qui a dit le gel hydroalcoolique ne
sert à rien le gilera ou très bonnes
réponses quand nicolas pernikoff qui
faire ça loana à l'automne loana qu'a
dit le gel hydroalcoolique ne sert à
rien non samedi dernier samedi didier
raoult et est apte à vous et par laurent
ruquier dans son émission on est en
direct et à chaque interview du
professeur à on prononce des petites
phrases qui font beaucoup parler faut
savoir laurent wauquiez a fait 10% de
part de marché samedi alors qu'il avait
un fort boyard avant à 6 % 1 voilà donc
il est il est au dessus de 2 fort boyard
en parts de marché et samedi il ya
professeur raoult qui a fait énormément
parler
et lorsqu'il a affirmé que le gel et les
masques ne servait à rien rené on aura
bien sûr votre à la disent regarde on a
eu treize mille patients affectés si je
ne sais pas été affectés dont 15 h elle
parce que c'est important
est ce qu'on dit là parce que j'ai
l'impression qu'on fait tout le
contraire en ce moment le jeune
aujourd'hui hydro alcooliques dans le
gène ne sert à rien ah bon c'est
l'alcool pour pouvoir avoir le gel il
fallait qu'ils aient un peu d'ordre et
d'oxygéner un peu d'alcool un peu de
gélatine donc tout ça au fur et à mesure
on complexifie sadien des produits qui
sont vendus alors qu'il suffit de foot
de l'alcool dans l'autre puis ça suffit
ça veut dire quand même que l'alcool est
donc plus important que le masque or
j'ai la pression pour nous tout le
contraire depuis de vous contredire mais
j'ai l'impression qu'on nous dit tout le
contraire depuis des mois et des mois
alors oui raymond moi je pense que pour
le gène il n'a pas tout à fait tort
parce que moi je suis un métier où je me
coupe souvent avec des palettes avec des
morceaux de verre j'ai toujours des
petits bouts de peau qui sont ouverts et
parfois je mets du gène jeu sans rien du
tout et d'autres gels jeu mais ça me
pique donc si ça me pique c'est qu'il ya
d'alcool c'est que ça marche si tu m'a
injecté ouvert pour couper vous chez
vous mettez déjà les allées voir la bête
il ya des jeunes que tu mets ça ne fait
rien du tout ça pique pas si au delà le
temps de ses sens impliqué si je suis
ouvert alors sa salle à allah et brut
mais dieu violemment ces brutes mais
c'est bien faire il a levé la main et
c'est pas pour dire une connerie
gilbert des alors j'ai trouvé que
c'était une très bonne interview il est
à l'air marseille avait plein de choses
dans les questions mais les réponses
sont scandaleuses pourquoi réponse du
professeur à eau sont scandaleux prévôté
il dit le gel ne sert à rien alors que
les gens depuis des mois on nous dit
mesures barrières mettez du gel
il dit ça ne passe pas ça ne passe que
par les mains et pas par les postillons
et c'est ce qu'il a dit mais rim et ben
moi je vous prends un exemple
et donc je vous jure j'ai été dans le
rer quelqu'un avait pas le masque j'ai
dit les gars c'est pas raisonnable et le
gars m'a dit il ya un grand professeur
hier jeudi le professeur raoul cadix à
ça ne sert à rien et les postillons donc
les postillons de côte c'est vrai ça
mais c'était dans leur dos rer d à viry
châtillon et ben ça c'est dégueulasse de
dire ça parce que les gens maintenant ne
vont plus maître de masques cause de lui
prenait les mecs ericsson responsable et
fera ici il y en a qui croient en
professeur en août comme moi j'écoutais
c'était très grands scientifiques que
moi et vacances arrivent tout le monde
le fait mais tout le monde fait sympa ne
comprendra la même les failles c'est
tout ça il ya des gains qui con paris et
vous dites il a tort mais scientifique
mondialement connue en nous les petits
comme on dit il attend je fais comme
qu'elle sahara août comme date 9 en
moyenne 15 jones ce truc
hubert faudrait que tu arrêtes de pastis
un jour moi je suis pour traîner à la
fin de cette crise le pakistan afin que
devons nous réjouir pour le traîner
leurs nouvelles grilles je suis pour le
traîner devant les tribunaux pour mise
en danger de la vie de la société que
simplement on ces propos sont choquants
l'ady gil avant qui mettent en danger
les gens il a [ __ ] pas deuxième vague
les gens ont relâché la pression
maintenant a indiqué matt ne servent à
rien que j'ai ne sert à rien à la longue
on adore le hockey sera mission du monde
entier mais faut pas rêver
moi je veux dire que j'ai trouvé très
bon samedi soir pour dix ans et j'ai
plein de préparer le trouve très bon
feeling et de contradictions et je pense
qu'il ya une énorme jalousie le taux
d'écouté sera ou assassin's creed
oui non mais après c'est une façon de
dire les choses mais je vois pas ce cas
de révolte ans quand un mec te dis aux
moins jeunes font la vie ce qui marche
dans le gel c'est l'alcool donc ne
jamais à rien mais tu es de l'alcool pur
canton mais j'ai refusé mais en fait
on est en train de dire que ces jeux là
ne servent à rien si elles ne servent à
rien donc c'est pas ce qui manque c'est
sauna ça marche ça ne marche pas bien le
nettoyant ça ne sert à rien il sait que
ce soit hydro alcoolique faut qu'il ait
le plus d'alcool mais c'était quand la
peur en écosse alors je je je rejoins
par mois et non pardon mais oui c'est
rené wayne rooney
non mais je reconnais sur un truc
d'abord le professeur effectivement
c'est un grand scientifique 1 c'est un
des cinq plus grands scientifiques qui
ne sait pas s'exprimer au départ à la
télévision on va le chercher aujourd'hui
tous les rallyes - interviews le mec il
est quand même dans la recherche et la
il a donné sa vie à la recherche
donc il faut arrêter avec chercher tout
le temps par contre une chose importante
ça a été le premier à dire il faut
dépister isolé c'est ce qu'il a été le
premier à le faire à marseille
tout le monde se foutait de la gueule
parce qu'il y avait un vrai que à marcel
devant l'hôpital c'est ce que son
obsession c'est à dire des pistes et
isolées aujourd'hui nous on l'a pas fait
en france c'est à dire qu'on l'a fait à
partir du mois de septembre
lui il avait commencé à le faire à
marseille alors après aller chercher des
trucs oui effectivement il a raison
c'est de l'alcool qui fait le job a
juste du gel ou n'y a pas d'alcool
donc à un moment donné il faut arrêter
de trois permanences d'aller taper sur
des mecs qui ont un talent monstrueux
qui sont reconnus dans le monde entier
comment donner cassé comme beaucoup les
états unis ou ailleurs où ils seront dix
fois sur internet